Harvard has a long tradition of service
to all of our neighbors both near and far,
and it has been a key part of the University
since its founding.
Service is a core aspect of all we do at Harvard.
Service in terms of what we
discover and the ways it can change the
world. Service in the form of
teaching and communicating knowledge but also
service in the way
in which we relate to our community
both local,
national, and global.
Service experience gives Harvard students an
ability to try out ideas to understand
how they can have an impact on the
world around them.
How can we be vibrant and integral
parts of the communities in which we are
located.
So that we serve that through being
engaged with them, and it's not a one-way
interaction but rather a reciprocal
interaction, in which we understand what
we can bring to the communities in which
we're located, but we also understand what
those communities bring to us. We have a
program at Harvard
for service employees, it's called
the bridge program. Recently I attended a
celebration
of citizenship of the naturalization of
thirty three individuals who were
participants in the bridge program,
and a considerable part of their
preparation for their citizenship exams
took place in conjunction with
undergraduate students, who tutored them
on aspects of american history, american
government, and other kinds of things
they needed to know for these
exams.
And wonderful relationships had grown up
between the undergraduate students and
the new american citizens, and this
celebration for me marked a marvelous
achievement by a group of our workers,
but also how marvelous example of
engagement by
our students. Tough
economic times make what we do all
the more important.
What we do in the communities that we
can help, that surround us and the ways
that we can translate skills and engagement
of our
students and faculty into helpful
interventions in communities life.
But also the ways in which our knowledge
can provide a means of service to help
us understand how to get out of these
times.
It's a teaching experience a learning
experience often for students and
integral part of their learning here at
Harvard.